[Applause]
welcome to swipe here's what's in store
thinking this week the scientist at the
top of UK innovation tells me how she's
changed the path for women
[Applause]
Angela's sounding out the tech to help
the new artist and two more is building
robots for the battlefield in our games
review stay with us for that and more
first though let's get a quick look at
some of the tech news headlines worth
knowing about this week whatsapp is
raising its minimum age limit to 16
across Europe at the moment users have
to be at least 13 years old but the
company is bringing in stricter rules
ahead of the introduction of new data
privacy rules in the EU next month
Amazon has started delivering to your
car boots
although you have to be parked in a
publicly accessible area in one of 37
American cities and have a certain type
of car it's made possible by using the
Amazon key app which also allows
homeowners to unlock their front doors
remotely so packages can be left inside
Australia's Monash University has
launched a wristbands that can tell if a
drink has been Speight it's called sip
safe and detects drugs in drinks when
aware a drops some of the liquid onto
the band and despite its recent woes of
Facebook's finances appear to have been
unaffected so far the social network
reported a 63% rise in profits in the
first three months of this year to three
point five seven billion pounds and an
increase in users
now women make up less than a quarter of
people working in stem that science tech
engineering and math it's a frustrating
reality but one that many have been
working hard to try and change one of
those people is dr. Ruth mckernon
she's the scientists at the top of the
UK's innovation agency but next week
she'll be stepping down from the role
before she does though she's had just
enough time to chat to swipe these women
our innovation role models brought
together to help get more female
entrepreneurs to apply for grants from
the government's innovation agency the
campaign was thought up by dr. Ruth
mckernon after she discovered a shocking
imbalance when we got the results it was
you know it was quite something only 14%
of the applications to innovate UK were
from women and as a senior woman a
female scientist this didn't sound right
so then of course you know the next
question is well why the information we
got really covered many different areas
so for some women it was not having role
models for others it was a confidence
thing for some it was about raising
money and what we found was that
actually women asked for less money when
they start companies which doesn't
necessarily build their credibility with
investors it's better to in some cases
asked for more money than you think
you're going to need Ruth's push to
spotlight female role models in her
women in innovation campaign worked the
best part about it is it took our female
applications from 14% to 24% like a 10%
increase in women applying for innovate
UK grants I think that's fantastic
do you think the tech industry is sexist
or do you think it's a simple case of
males prefer STEM subjects to females
I don't even agree with that actually so
I'm a neuroscientist by training and I
really like solving problems I really
like design I like to create things you
know that is actually part of what
people would think of as engineering or
technology so some of the skills that
women naturally bring to bear are
exactly the skills that the industries
of the future are going to need
I think women are the integrators in the
world they're the peacemakers
we're the people who helped pull teams
together if you're trying to create a
team you want a diverse team if you
don't have a good number of women on
your team you won't have diversity you
won't get the best results and you won't
get economically good businesses after
three years at the top of innovate UK
Ruth is just days away from stepping
down the government describes her as a
champion for diversity within innovation
so what advice does she have for the new
generation of women entrepreneurs just
do what you really care about so when I
when I was maybe 13 or 14 I had two
choices I was either going to be a
scientist like my dad or I was going to
be an airhostess
because I really liked the idea of
traveling in the end I followed my
passion which was science and that meant
I could travel all over the world and so
my advice would be follow your passion
be the best that you can be in who you
are and what you care about because from
that other things will follow don't
fight the battles about whether this is
the right job for the woman or not the
right job for a woman do what you really
care about that's how you'll be
successful we're talking music now
because fair payments to artists chasing
the backing of a record label and
keeping fans engaged are just some of
the struggles faced by musicians so what
solutions and innovations are there to
make things easier angela has been in
Dublin to find out the music industry
invests billions of pounds each year to
seek out new talent but many are left
behind
one startup thinks they can solve that
here's Anderson makers of a digital
artists and repertoire app it uses
predictive analytics and artificial
intelligence to connect unsigned acts
directly to industry executives it means
if a label is setting out to find
someone who sounds like Taylor Swift its
algorithm will detect those who actually
do in Ireland if you were to go on one
of these every artist under the Sun tags
themselves as hozier I guarantee you
know 99% of them don't sound like those
are what we do is tag it based on this
audio AI so there's sort of no escaping
what you sound like
once signed the challenge for labels is
keeping fans engaged so they're looking
for new ideas
we spoke to wolf3d they want to make
concert experiences more immersive by
letting fans create their own 3d avatars
of their friends for example via an app
available in virtual and augmented
reality the goal is to bring real people
into virtual spaces so it can be a game
you know you can play games with your
own character or it can be a VR concert
in the music industry for example going
to a concert with your friends and all
using your avatar so I have a real
friends in there with you a challenge
both labels and artists face is
unauthorized music streaming so they
don't miss out on getting paid Valerio
showed us it's smart speaker the device
which lets you tip an artist when you
hear a song you like giving them more
money in addition to royalties it's
powered by blockchain technology with
payments in digital currency crypto the
blockchain technology means more
transparency so that is both useful for
musicians in the sense that the right
people are benefiting financially
from music streaming and immediately as
well mixed augmented and virtual reality
blockchain artificial intelligence and
new live immersive experiences are all
changing the music industry landscape
and how we encounter it but is this
technology changing the music industry
for the better or worse music streaming
service teaser and no strangers to the
challenges the industry faces and
continue to look for ways to convert
people from consuming free music to
paying for it that comes down to several
things first of all quality quality of
service quality of sound the ability to
find tracks store them and also share
them but it also comes down to the whole
user experience of experiencing music in
high sound quality and on cross device
[Music]
whether new technologies can cure the
industry's ills remains to be seen but
many of those making music hope it will
help them make the money that keeps
their careers going Angela band Sky News
video games time now and this week it's
two Moore's turn in the swipe game
studio here he is with three of the
latest releases
[Music]
first up this week we have don't star
for the switch which is a brutal and
punishing survival game where you're
foraging for resources and fighting
enemies you play a tiny little terrified
character in a timber inspired well all
you've got to do is spend your days
finding resources and crafting what you
need to survive and at night holding the
darkness at bay and holding on to your
mental sanity it's a very difficult game
you will die a lot but that's part of
the point on Nintendo switch it lets you
pick up and play whenever you want and
take it at your own pace this means the
stresses of dying over and over again
are lessened all you've got to do is
turn it on spend a little time grabbing
some resources building a fire getting
some food finding some water and then
come back later on to take on the night
where you fight some enemies and do some
more exploring don't starve is a simple
really satisfying game and it's even
better on the switch Chuck has already
been released for the PC Xbox one and
ps4 but now it's finally arrived on the
switch this time around instead of
poking fun at Dungeons & Dragons it's
having a laugh at the expense of the
superhero movie genre most notably The
Avengers you play as a new kid and
arrive in town to inevitably get
embroiled in one of Cartman's
get-rich-quick schemes again this time
around it's all about superheroes as the
new kid you get to craft your own
character and pick what superhero powers
you want to use and take into battle its
turn-based gameplay which means you've
got the time to dip in and out as you
please and on the switch that's perfect
if you're traveling
on top of all the battling and
questioning you'll get the time to
explore South Park itself and inevitably
you'll run into the various quirky
characters that you find in the town
South Park is a quirky role-playing game
which will poke fun at all your favorite
superheroes you can play on the go which
means it's easy to dip in and out of and
perfect for the switch again Robocraft
infinity is a quirky and fun PC and Xbox
one game that I know you'll love it
leans on something that everyone enjoys
building and battling growing up
everyone builds stuff whether that's
with Legos or bits and pieces just
around the house and in this game it
gives you blocks and ask you to build
pretty much anything you want to take
into battle that could be a car about a
plane or a Tyrannosaurus Rex that biased
laser beams from its eyes all you've got
to do is put the blocks in places and
then customize it at any movement Styles
you want and weapons and then take it
online to battle if you don't feel like
building you can use the factory to
download other people's creations and
customize them or take them into battle
as is Robocraft infinite is great
because it draws upon the innate joy we
get from building stuff except this time
you get to destroy it too on the
Internet
well that's it for this week's show
don't forget to join us again for more
swype next week and in the meantime why
not follow us on twitter at sky news
swipe that you can see what we get up to
throughout the week bye bye
[Applause]
you